hello everyone and welcome back to the
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong show Jacqueline
Coley is here with me I'm Mark Ellis and
Jacqueline I kick it over to you with a
simple phrase and I think you know where
I'm going with this Yoo-hoo
I'll make you famous
oh this is the day this is the day that
I've been waiting for since August of
1990 and I'm sure yeah let's finish the
game let's finish the game and that game
will be finished with Jacqueline myself
and our very special guest today Mr Alan
Ruck who will be talking with us about
Young Guns too he plays Henry William
French slash Buckshot George for a brief
second there in Young Guns two the movie
came out like I said in August of 1990
and Jacqueline a crime against humanity
and particularly the old west has been
committed here because the Tomato Meter
says that Young Guns too which I thought
was like 40 a couple months ago it's now
down to 29
rotten it does Rebound with the audience
score at 66 percent but um I I hope Alan
rock is on the same page as us where
this movie deserves in fresh feel I hope
he is I mean he's the one that picked
this I know anyone listening to the
podcast is going to assume that you and
I like slip like stacked the deck and
gave him like 10 choices but eight of
which was Young Guns too and the other
two were like
Paddington too anyway no
um we know this is his choice and I
agree man it is a it is a crime it is a
travesty although not surprising because
again the original was was 40 something
percent rotten and westerns usually
don't fare that well but we know better
we know better it was it was one of my
gripes about the the celebrated Rotten
Tomatoes book
um that was sort of the rotten movies we
love is the name of the book talking
about rotten movies that we still
celebrate Young Guns one is in that book
with an essay and I told our
editor-in-chief at the time Joel Mears
that I want to write Young Guns Too when
the sequel to that book comes out so
that dream still alive and again Alan
Ruck is our special guest we're going to
be joined with in just a little bit here
and you know him obviously is Cameron
from Ferris Bueller day off Young Guns
Too for Jacqueline and I he currently
stars in the hit HBO show succession
he's also been everything from Star Trek
generations he was in twister the sky
when you think about everything that
he's done he's done I'm glad that we get
to talk about Young Guns but he can come
back for a lot of different episodes
well you said that there's a lot within
the world of Young Guns too and just
fair warning everybody at the end of the
interview hopefully if I get time I need
to ask him about this poster conundrum
that I'm in right now I have a Young
Guns 2 poster it's not with me if you
keep listening you'll hear the reason
why yes Nathan I'm talking to you
your property basically you don't I
don't really know if you can call it
yours you could say that you have it's
sort of like my mortgage it's like the
bank really owns it but I'm the one that
has to pay the bill like that's
everything wrong right now yeah Outlaw
to get this poster back and I am willing
to do so I'm willing to take this and go
right down to Old Mexico and live out
the rest of my days
um but let's talk about Young Gun Sue
Jacqueline you have the joyous task of
giving us the synopsis for Young Guns
Too what is this movie about for anybody
who hasn't seen it yet yeah first of all
shame on you but yes Young Guns Too is
the seminal follow-up to the amazing hit
Young Guns which sort of details Billy
the Kid's emergence from the Lincoln
County wars which was a territory cattle
wrestling War that's the events of the
first one in the sequel we find Billy
still on the Run making a name for
himself as Billy the Kid and he's
essentially trying to get the game back
together uh Doc and Chavez are being
held uh awaiting hanging he's trying to
make a deal with the governor so he can
get pardoned and maybe live out his day
somewhere and in doing so he enlists
some new faces like Christian Slater
playing uh Arkansas Dave rudabaugh also
our illustrious guest today Mr Alan Rupp
playing Henry William French and a host
of other folks including his former
partner Pat Garrett The Man Who is
credited with killing him
um on the hunt to sort of bring him to
justice that group bringing him to
Justice also includes a before he was
famous but still awesome Vigo Mortensen
and all of this is framed under the
guise of Brushy Bill Roberts who in 1940
something 50 something said that he was
Billy the Kid and tried to get credit
for that and sort of the story kicks off
with him telling the story of Young Guns
Too as a very old man and we sort of
follow their Adventures to try and find
a Mexican Blackbird and make their way
into
he's telling the story of Bradley to a
young Bradley Whitford yeah to a young
Bradley Whitford before The West Wing
but after Revenge of the Nerds as my
friend Greg from college would say
um a phenomenal cast and so that's who
we're going to be talking Young Guns to
with is one of the members of that great
cast but before we do it's time to hear
what the critics were saying at the time
of Young Guns too because I I can't
imagine why this movie was rotten to
begin with and the fact that it sucks at
29 is a crime against all Cowboys and
horses alike so let's get to two minutes
with Tim this is our segment where Tim
Ryan gives us the breakdown on what the
film reviewers were saying at the time
of the movie's release Tim take it away
I'm going to start by reading a quote
from a July 22nd 1881 New York Times
article about the death of Billy the Kid
in appearance Billy was one of the
mildest persons imaginable his soft blue
eye was so attractive that those who saw
him for the first time looked upon him
as a victim of circumstance stances in
spite of his innocent appearance however
Billy the Kid was really one of the most
dangerous characters which this country
has produced Henry McCarty aka William H
Bonnie AKA Billy the Kid was dead by 21
but as the aforementioned article
indicates the mass media treated him
like a pop Idol and by the time of his
death his exploits had already been
elevated into the realm of myth a lot of
critics chuckled about the fresh-faced
cast and the flashy MTV style of the
Young Guns movies but in retrospect that
actually seems like one of the most
realistic things about them but at a
time when the general consensus was that
the Western as a genre was dying and
with Decades of Billy the Kid movies to
reckon with including Arthur pens the
left-handed gun starring Paul Newman or
Sam peckinpaw's Pat Garrett and Billy
the Kid critics found Young Guns Too
lack the grit and kravitas of the great
westerns of the past Young Guns 2 is
rotten to 29 on the Tomato Meter with 24
reviews though it does have a 66
audience score and just for comparison
the original Young Guns is rotten at 41
so what did the critics have to say in a
round review Janet Maslin of the New
York Times wrote that as played by
Emilio Estevez Billy tends to giggle a
tense moments and during important ones
to mumble the other members of the
Lincoln County Regulators Billy's gang
share a similar boyishness that's geared
far more carefully to the taste of
today's teenage audiences than to the
folklore of the old west however in a
fresh review Michael Wilmington of the
Los Angeles Times wrote full of sound
gunfire Fury and scorchingly beautiful
landscapes Young Guns Too generates more
sheer visual excitement than any Western
since pecan paw and Leone were in their
late 70s Prime so that's Young Guns too
let's kick it back to Jacqueline and
Mark who at various points have
individually been described as Devils on
the Run Six Gun lovers and candles in
the Wind
yeah
back to you folks yeah
Jacqueline I just just a note to every
critic in 1990. uh not every cowboy in
the old west needs to be played by old
John Wayne or ancient Clint Eastwood
okay so the movie's called Young Guns
were you expecting to see your dad as
Billy the Kid I mean also the biggest
parts of Billy the kids
he was kind of a teenager legit man like
he died at 21 do you think and also too
I I think people forget man it's 16
you're damn near ready to marry back
then you know like this was not this was
not the same timeline here it's a short
life when you lived in the old west you
lived and died by the sword or gun as
the case may be and so now I'm fired up
I'm ready to get rolling let's talk
about this movie let's talk about
succession let's see who should be the
rightful owner of my Young Guns 2 poster
and let's bring in Mr Alan Rock and as
promised here on the show we have an
actor who's been part of our lives on
stage and screen for decades you
probably remember him as Cameron from
Ferris Bueller's Day Off right through
his current run as Conor Roy on
succession which is now in its third
season on HBO you can catch it airing on
Sunday nights but the reason why we
bring him here today we wanted to have
him on it as a guest anyway but the fact
that Alan Ruck chose Young Guns 2 as his
movie Alan it's such a pleasure to have
you on the show can you confirm that
there was no arm twisting from either
Jacqueline or myself or huge Young Guns
to fans that this is actually the movie
you wanted to talk about right well I
said I really don't know what to talk
about and then a list was supplied a
movie that I happened to be in was on it
and I'm like well I can talk about that
I know something about that one yeah
okay well good that's something that's
fair enough because Jacqueline and I
have been shouting from the rooftops on
podcasts on stage wherever we can about
the Praises of Young Guns too and so you
play Henry William French in the movie
and before we get into the specifics
your experience talking about our
favorite scenes just as as simply as you
can possibly say here is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong about Young Guns too because it
currently is 29 rotten yes Tomato Meter
the stink factor is set in it's like
it's like putrification is set in
um yeah I do disagree with that I mean
you know everybody's is entitled to
their opinion
um uh there's a couple things about the
movie that I would have done differently
had I produced it or directed it but not
actually directed it had I produced it
but
um mostly I think I I think it's a
pretty good Western and um I think
there's some amazing actors in it you
know so I I do disagree with the 29
percent
that's bad I mean that's that's that's
pretty low yeah and it just dropped
again recently I remember it being I
dropped again her 30s and so but but
this is why we do the show here and it's
great having you on the team because I
want to say that Jacqueline we probably
took Sister Act 2 up at least 10 or 15
percentage points and so I think we can
do the same for Young Guns too that's
amazing that's amazing I want to be part
of this okay yeah also you might add it
the original is not exactly a sterling
example of freshness either and it got a
sequel so let's just be honest they knew
what they were going into this so I'm
like I'm like whatever this is a fun
movie yeah yeah yeah
I mean 66 on the audience score so the
audience score is fresh which is sort of
the redeeming value of Young Guns too is
that it was made for us audiences and we
do indeed love it Jacqueline what would
you say is Rotten Tomatoes wrong I
assume I know your answer definitely
wrong I I don't I mean honestly yeah we
follow that guy ability to kid but let's
be honest when the real protagonist Mr
French comes up is when you really kick
for the high gear no it's a great film I
love Lou Diamond Phillips he's actually
from my hometown of Corpus Christi I
love the score about Alan Silvestri also
the songs by Jon Bon Jovi and it's just
a really fun Western with all of the fun
Western elements and you know Keith or
Sutherland is Doc it just I don't know
how people can't have fun with these
characters and in some ways although
it's very different than the original
it's like even more enjoyable you get he
gets a Bradley Whitford in the opening I
mean how can you go wrong with this I
don't know how people couldn't love it
well boy I'm glad to hear that that's
yeah that's nice thank you yeah so legit
like me and Mark we're not joking talk
about this movie all the time I've
interviewed Alan Silvestri and people
want to talk to him about Back to the
Future and Forrest Gump I'm like let's
talk about Young Guns
the score is amazing as is the
soundtrack rack and so when we when we
come to to Alan Rock's participation in
Young Guns Too as Henry William French
or for about five seconds buck shot
George your experience and and you're
filming of the movie I was reading that
you showed up a couple weeks early on
set just so you could kind of get the
the feel of riding a horse and using
weapons on a horse and all that stuff
and you were working with like real
Wranglers and Ranch hands did you feel
like Billy Crystal in City Slickers when
you're just meeting these people for the
first time that feeling has not really
left me
um I went to north of Los Angeles here
to uh the the ranch of this this fellow
named Jack Lily who's an old-time cowboy
actor stunt man Wrangler and uh I took
some riding lessons up there
and uh because uh Jeff Murphy the
director I went in and I
in the British fashion he didn't make me
audition he just interviewed me you know
so I sat down I talked with this guy and
then they offered me this part so it was
the whole thing was painless and then um
I said but you should know that I I I I
haven't ridden a horse since I was 10
years old and then it was only for about
five minutes and he said don't worry
we'll yeah we'll take it there's a guy
we're gonna send it to and he'll take
lessons
um yeah I got I got dumped really hard
twice in that movie uh there's uh
there's this one horse that later uh
dumped and dragged Lou Philip and broke
his arm Lou Diamond Phillips and uh he
was described the horse was described by
the Cowboys as being a ranked prick
um I don't know if we I don't know what
we can say but we were we were uh we
were just rehearsing and um apparently
there's something wrong with the bit in
the horse's mouth it had a little sharp
edge of something and so I tried to
Reign him back
and he started bucking I mean he started
bucking like this and I was scared out
of my mind and I heard Lou uh yelling
like Ryan Alan
you know and um then I hit the ground
really hard and uh uh one of the Cowboys
a guy named Daniel Lee Spacey I don't
think he's on the planet anymore but he
said if you lasted two more seconds you
would have made the rodeo
yeah I think I think I lasted for a
whole four seconds before the horse got
me off his back so that was you know
yeah I I there were many visits to the
chiropractor after that movie wow yeah
yeah what you did for your craft sir we
appreciate it we really do yeah well I'm
glad I'm glad it's not all you know
sunglasses well I have a question too
about it because since you can give us a
bit of the behind the scenes was there
anyone who's particularly great at the
horse work on the team do you remember
yeah I mean uh this is the first time I
met Vigo and this was before Vigo became
a big star yeah you know and um he and
the southern this Cowboy Daniel Lee and
I we sort of became the three-headed
monster we just kind of hung out
together for a while in uh Old Tucson uh
Vigo would go on his uh off days on his
free days he would go over to uh the
ranch right outside of town right
outside of Tucson where they kept I
don't know how how many horses there
were but there had to be 40 40 or 50
horses and um he would go in and he
would feed them he would break up the
hay and he would feed them by hand and
then he would find something to step up
on and he would get up on them bareback
and hold on to their Mane you know and
he would ride them around bareback just
gently around the pen so he had a re he
was like The Horse Whisperer of of all
of us he really was he was really tuned
in to to those horses it's you can you
can see the authenticity and and the the
care that the performers like yourself
put into you know really wanting to do a
lot of their own stunts and and riding
the horses and and working with all the
weapons and stuff and then you cut two
the first time you actually saw the
movie I I assume it was that a Premiere
situation of some sort when you see the
finished product did you have any
visceral reaction right away to what you
were watching yeah I mean the truth was
in that movie I played the sad sorry guy
and that's not who you want to play in a
western you want to be the guy like
Christian Slater had a scene where he
rode his horse through a plate class
window and started shooting people
that's really who you want to be you
don't want to be you know The Grieving
widower it's it's not that exciting in
Western
um but I I thought it was really uh I
thought it was really well done I
thought Jeff Murphy did a great job I
thought it was beautifully shot
um that was Dean semler I believe was a
cinematographer and um you know just
world class
cameraman uh so I it was just I thought
it was I thought it was a big beautiful
movie you know Jacqueline what did you
first see Young Guns too because I'm a
little older than you so you probably
missed it in the theaters right yeah I
didn't see this one in the theaters
because I think I was like seven or six
seven eight somewhere in there what it
says seven when this came out and my mom
was definitely not about it but we had a
great thing which it's called Encore
stars now but it used to be called
Encore just like plain Encore and the
main thing they played on that was
Western like westerns a lot of like
things from like the early 70s it wasn't
it was old movies but it was old movies
that were not on TCM but around the same
time period so like TCM was all the like
very highly rated stuff so like awkward
did everything else and I saw it on
Encore and that was great because I got
to see all the cursing and all of the
like stuff it wasn't like the TNT
version which I've watched since then
it's not as good yeah I loved it it I
thought it was like I was initially like
shut down for it and then also because I
was an MTV kid I did get to watch then
Bon Jovi and then perform
uh you know like uh at the at the awards
when he was like nominated for best
music song yeah Blaze of Glory that
video was everywhere and so just quick
boring story that actually leads into
our memorable scenes from the movie is I
remember seeing the movie and it was one
of the first theater experiences I had
just me and my older sister going to the
movies by ourselves my mom dropping us
off watching Young Guns too and the
reason we were so excited is six months
earlier we were seeing another movie in
the theater it might have been Batman
1980 I can't remember what it was but
there were two trailers that I
distinctly remember one was for The
Exorcist three because I had just gotten
over how scared The Exorcist made me
when I had initially seen it and then
you know the the one it's been 17 years
since he walked these steps and I'm like
damn it we're doing this again and then
the next trailer came on was this movie
franchise I'd never heard of the first
Young Guns and we we see all these
sweeping Western shots and and then the
end of the trailer was Billy the Kid
Emilio Estevez pulling his gun and
saying Yoo-hoo I'll make you famous and
that stuck with me and my sister and I
left whatever movie we were watching
afterwards saying we need to immediately
bookmark when that movie comes in the
theaters just because that line alone
was so important to me and my entire
life since then just the way just the
Cockiness with which he delivers it how
its clever trash talk that probably
wouldn't get a flag thrown on in the NFL
but you're still letting your opponent
know I'm better at this than you and
that is one of my favorite scenes but
it's also not just because of how cool
and cowboy Billy the Kid is it's also
because in a similar scene where it you
Alan Rock's character uh Henry William
French is standing up to John Chisholm
the man who stole your farm because
point you can say that you're sort of
the sad sack of the movie but when push
comes to shove and your back's against
the wall you will stand up for yourself
so that scene was just it was such a
great part of a great movie yeah I'm
glad we had such wonderful people on
that movie I mean uh James Coburn yeah
come on we had um
well Billy Peterson I knew from Chicago
for my days in Chicago so that was
really uh fun to have him playing Pat
Garrett and uh we had Leon Rippy we had
Tracy Walter we had Jack Kehoe we had
Scott Wilson I mean these are like some
really big Hollywood heavyweight
character actors you know and then uh
James Coburn I mean I mean movie Legend
so uh yeah so what was it like yeah I
was gonna say what was it like going you
know giving it to James Culver to see it
like I just imagine that's all my
highlight reel for forever
I I you know okay I'm gonna I've never
told this but anyway between between
takes you know I was doing it like you
know down home hillbilly accent and um
Coburn leaned over to somebody and he
said I love what he's doing
you know and so I was like wow that
that'll carry me for 30 years
love that what's the scene for you Alan
that stands out if you're just watching
the the completed film and you say oh
that that was the scene that really
elevates the picture
there's uh I mean there's there's a
number of moments I don't know if I can
just pin it down to one there there's a
scene where um it's a slow push in on
Billy Peterson as Pat Garrett and I
can't remember the context now but he's
just he's he's really conflicted he's
scared and um I mean he's really fine
actor Bill and I just think
I think a trap with playing these
Legends is that they can you know it's
just like oh here's the guy that you
know was the fastest gun in the west or
whatever and you can you can fall into
cliches but I think what everybody did
in that movie was uh bring a human
element to it and so when people were
scared they let you see it it's like
yeah I mean they still went ahead and
Drew their pistols but that didn't mean
they weren't scared out of their minds
you know
um
the different comedic bits that ran
through the film The Jack Kehoe who kept
saying I I need to stop I need to have a
movement I need to have a movement right
and then something happens and scares
the hell out of ego's character and he
just quietly says that Miss Vigo way I
think I need to have a movement you know
I mean
I just thought it was I think John Fusco
did a really good job uh with that
screenplay I thought it was entire and
complete and um I just had a I had a I
had a ball I mean I got beat up a lot
but with the horse thing but um I was
thrilled to be part of a western I think
maybe I have one more in me I just have
to go to the gym and I have to get my
legs really strong you know so I can do
it but I think I'd like to do one more
Western before it's all over it's all
about the squats man it's you get the
quads and the hams loose and ready to
ride get those abductors and adductors
down there ready to ride first one more
time and you know what happened it's
funny Alan brings up that scene because
the juxtaposition of of Pat Garrett's
character played by William Peterson who
everybody loves from CSI and every time
CSI is on I'm like that's that's Pat
Garrett it's like you see him when he's
off when he's offered the money because
he starts out friends with Billy the Kid
and then he gets offered all this money
that he'll never have to be a ranch hand
again and we see him with still with the
mutton chops and he's kind of mulling
this deal over and then the next time we
see him he's like the man in Black and
he's just got all this new clothes and
he's doing the pistol and he's like
ready to go get Billy the Kid it's
another great scene in the movie what's
what's Jaclyn Coley's scene that you
point to and you say that's why I love
this movie I mean
that Lou Diamond Phillips does in that
movie like when he does the moment when
him and Doc get thrown into the pit and
he's just like going through he's like
the spirit horse will come to you if you
reach the other side Doc's like I don't
want to reach this and I was like me
neither like I love that joke I thought
that was such a great joke
um I also loved when Billy shoots the
deputy from the window and he's like
best book 85 respect and I love that
uh yeah I mean there's so many and I
guess I'm like leaning in on the on the
comedic moments of it but you know even
even the more I would say less comedic
but I think interesting
um what's her name and I'll need to look
up her name right right quick but when
she walks when she rides out of town
yeah just like sis get it those roles
for women in those movies are very
limited to begin with but I just really
loved that her yeah her riding out in
that moment
um yeah also what's that character's
name Jane Jane great house is that what
it was Jane Jane great house and she
says I think the town is white ocean she
says you can kiss my ass and then for
for a 10 year old in the movie theater
watching the big screen I'm not gonna
say that was my least favorite scene I
don't know exactly I'm sure you found
that very interesting yeah yeah and I
was gonna say Alan if you do know the
Western please do we just had
where we talked to uh
Timpson and he
and he is the lead in Old Henry where he
plays like legit like a very sort of
John Wick type character where you don't
know this person's skills until it's too
late type thing so I could totally see
you playing into that Universe sir you
know what I'm saying like that is
literally in your wheelhouse that kind
of like you don't know what I come to
bring
um uh to the table I like that though
that's what I like about westerns
everyone's got a back story it seems
like before we get to the film well
their life was so hard I mean you just
figure that the people that actually
survived they had something going on
even if you know
you couldn't judge a book by its cover
but I mean they had they had some skills
otherwise they never would have survived
and you get to see more of more of that
life I feel like in Young Guns too
because I'm a fan of the first one but
Emilio Estevez has a quote that I think
is very accurate we're talking about the
first Young Guns he says it was like the
first heavy metal Western where there it
feels like there's a lot of modernisms
in the old west in that movie and we're
really just looking at these characters
getting together but Young Guns Too
feels more like a Sergio Leone movie
because we get some of those huge
sweeping shots with the the Epic Alan
Silvestri score and you just feel like
you get to know what it actually feels
like to live and die in the old west and
that's sort of the Fallout of that movie
and it's something that I always am
hesitant when I put the movie on which
is probably way too frequently is
towards the end you know we're saying
goodbye to a lot of these characters at
least we think because we lose we lose
doc we lose Arkansas Dave goes to Mexico
and it doesn't end up well for him but
Henry William French makes it
yeah well he just he he stepped away at
the right time
so brilliant listen you gotta know when
to hold him and know when to fold them
wait a minute this is this is a really
fun ride guys but
um here's where I get off this
particular train
um
it was you know it was it was really
exciting poor Lou that same horse that
dumped me in rehearsal they were doing
this
setup where they're breaking Chavez out
of jail and so Lou's hands were behind
his back and uh tied
and so he didn't have a any way to get
to his Bridle Reigns
and uh one of the Wranglers Steve Hannah
said get some fishing wire and let you
know some fishing line and hook him up
to the range so I can hold the reins off
camera uh and they didn't really know
how crazy this horse was because they
were shooting spark balls they shoot
it's like an air gun that shoots a
little thing that makes it hits bricks
and it makes Sparks so it looks like a
bullet you know
and um they were shooting those and this
horse was really Twitchy and um
so Steve Hannah said let me hold this
horse they said no we can't because
we'll see you in the shot and sure
enough they shot up a spark ball and
that horse took off loose hands were
behind his back
he fell off the horse but one foot was
stuck in the Stirrup and was dragging
him
out into the desert and the only reason
uh where were we at that time we were in
we were in New Mexico and the only
reason
um he didn't get dragged to his death is
because his arm hit a wagon wheel a
parked wagon shattered his uh arm but
that was what loosened him up from the
horse otherwise he would have been
dragged to death in the dark we never
would have found him probably until a
day later you know whoa and um yeah and
um we were supposed to go out to dinner
uh after he was going to call me up when
he got off uh work and we were going to
go out and grab something to eat
apparently Lou the badass said to as
they were putting him in the ambulance
he said tell Alan I won't be able to
make it for supper
yeah my respect for early Diamond
Phillips has just gained exponentially
yeah
well that's sort of like the movie theme
itself like that's Pals for you you know
that's really just willing to willing to
stick it out for your friends and when
you look at this in the con because that
scene is also another one of my
favorites because of that one look that
you see on Lou Diamond Phillips's face
as Chavez where it's this Lynch Mob and
they're coming to exercise the mob
justice so that the town or the the
pilot the politicians don't have to get
their hands dirty with these Outlaws
we're just gonna have a mob do it but
Billy is disguised as a winch mobber and
he brings some of his boys with him
instead and the look on Chavez's face
when he hears the laugh because the
first time the doc gets thrown into the
pit after he gets you know taken away
from New York he asked Chavez where is
he and we're speaking about Billy and
they they don't have any clue where he
is and when he hears that laugh it's
just you see that it's a quick moment
but you just see all of these emotions
and these feelings of riding with The
Regulators watch over him in that one
scene and then as you said all hell
breaks loose and and bullets are firing
and Arkansas Dave is riding a horse
through a play weight class when and
that's the kind of stuff that you love
seeing in westerns right there yeah
absolutely this I was very envious of
Christian Slater that I mean actually
wasn't him it was a stunt man but it's
just that he was the guy that got to
ride through play Class Window I was
just about to say I don't think I mean
don't be wrong he was awesome in
Heather's and in cuffs but I just don't
think that he had built up those much
you know uh no I mean no and you did you
wanna you wanna leave that to the
professionals I mean you know even guys
to do their own stunts they know when to
say when and um you know there's some
things it's like just leave it to the
people that really know how yeah it's
something that I've always wrestled with
about the mythology of Billy the Kid and
and I love the way that this movie's
framed with old Brushy Bill Roberts and
was he or wasn't he actual Billy the Kid
but it's it's a conundrum right because
he's not a hero and the one role my mom
had when she dropped us off at Young Gun
store I still remember saying like Okay
kids just remember uh he's not a hero
he's not a good guy so as long as you
know that I guess he's like an anti-hero
but I even have problems calling that
because the whole premise of Young Gun
series he's leading y'all on a wild
goose chase that ends up being something
that he invented and so there's that
question of when are you a good leader
versus when are you just wanting to hang
out with your friends and leading them
down the wrong path how do you Rectify
these movies that sort of celebrate
Billy the Kid or do you think that they
do a good job of kind of showing the
real person that we that we think we
know
well one one thing that I think uh Young
Guns Too does well is it shows how
corrupt the powers that be are and so
um whether Billy the Kid was a hero
whether he was a bad guy he was he was
both uh I mean but uh the truth is that
he stood up to some people
who uh should have been doing a better
job as as public servants and they were
they were thoroughly corrupt
and um so I just think
she wasn't about to let anybody like
that tell him how to lead his life or
you know I mean a true a true Rebel and
uh I think that's one thing that the
movie does really well it shows that
well maybe these guys were wild and
maybe yeah they got in gunfights and
they you know some people got killed but
um the circumstances they were in there
wasn't much of a choice it was either do
that or lie down and let people walk all
over you
yeah the governor that whole like
storyline where he basically lies to him
I thought that was really interesting
too just like the idea that he was just
like I should have dusted his Excellency
yeah yeah yeah I I agree
um also even Colburn's character you
know men of that time if he because he
was the richest man in the territory
when he says I am New Mexico he wasn't
like hyperbole he really was at that
point he could do whatever there was no
law there was no any repercussions to
him just because he was the man in the
area with the most money which I think
uh you know it's kind of a Robin Hood
tail in that way absolutely and I mean
these these these you just realized that
things have always been this way I mean
in the old I mean wherever people wound
up being whoever the baron was or
whoever the landlord was or
I mean in the old days it was kings and
queens and Emperors and today it's
captains of industry and it's um so the
the dynamic doesn't really change
the titles change and uh maybe the
different areas of the world change time
periods change but um it's the same
struggle against
people who think they answer to no one
and and other people who say no no you
got to answer to me yeah if if John
Chisholm was alive today he probably
would be building a rocket to go up to
space for about 10 seconds
he'd be in the oil business he would
totally be a modern day Rockefeller too
if I mean we can't talk about Young Guns
Too without bringing up the legendary
soundtrack by Jon Bon Jovi and it's such
an interesting backstory because I guess
him and Emilio had been Pals on the
first Young Guns and they really were
they they played Wanted Dead or Alive on
set a lot just to kind of get into theme
and they approached Bon Jovi about using
that song and he said well yeah but
there's some Modern references I don't
really think it works let me try to
write something and then it didn't work
out for the original but it certainly
worked out for the sequel were you ever
on set when when Jon Bon Jovi was
hanging around because the war has it
that he was kind of scribbling blaze of
glory and and kind of wrote it in a day
while he was on set
I don't actually remember I wasn't uh I
wasn't in every scene I didn't work
every day and I don't really remember
him being on set though I know he was
there but I don't remember seeing him on
set I I met him sometime later when we
were doing uh press tours and promos and
so forth
um for the movie
um that doesn't surprise me at all that
that he wrote that in a day I mean I I
think when
uh when people get inspired when when
creativity strikes it usually it
actually usually happens fairly quickly
um I know that he's a big Western fan
um I know that he he's way into Cowboy
culture so that doesn't surprise me at
all that he dashed that off that quickly
um because when people have those gifts
um they're sort of obsessed and
possessed and it's just I have to get
this out of my head and onto paper you
know and so I think he's in his way he
has that same gift that like John Hughes
had John Hughes used to write scripts
over a weekend
um
and because he just it just was in his
head and he had to get it out so I that
doesn't surprise me at all about Bon
Jovi yeah and wrote a lot of scripts
that he didn't even want credit for he
didn't even ask credit for and just yeah
even more of our lives than we know yeah
he was he was playing games but he he
just wanted to escape Hollywood and he
did
yeah uh Jacqueline do you still fire up
that Young Guns 2 soundtrack like I do
uh this past weekend
I um yeah the score is so great I'm so
glad you brought that up too because it
does feel like ennio morricone that
opening shot and we just see all all
these guys riding towards what is going
to be a ruse from Billy and his gang at
that time it's just such a great way to
open a western yeah
yeah geez I mean as you said the the
man's list of credits uh it's pretty
impressive and um so I you know it was
um I think the first picture did did
pretty well at the box office I mean
enough to Merit a sequel and then I
think on the second movie
um I think they really did it right and
they hired some really
big Hollywood star actors to work with
us
um Jeff Murphy is he's gone now but he
was originally from New Zealand and um
he just had this sort of wild I think he
made his bones doing music videos and
and uh rock and roll footage in New
Zealand and he just had this kind of he
had in his own way he had little Outlaw
feel to him yeah um but they just hired
some really wonderfully talented people
and uh it's
so I do disagree with this 29 thing
even back at the time y'all got the last
laugh is um worked on pretty
90s where any movie that got over 50
million was making some you know what I
mean making some oh yeah in the box
office so and look look at the legacy of
it this is again not just a me and Mark
loved thing I know you have a a few
things that folks probably talk to you
more than often but can you do you like
hold a special place in your heart if
someone comes up to you and is like
they're not going to talk about Ferris
they're not going to talk about
succession they're like because I'm
basically hoping that if I met you you
would have been like she's cool because
she wants to talk about Young Thugs
oh you are cool
no matter what but uh uh yeah do you get
those folks like do you get one I used
to I don't I haven't done this in a
while but I used to go to those
autograph shows like Star Trek
conventions and stuff I was in a Star
Trek movie once and so it's just you
know it's Shameless you just go and you
know you sell pictures of yourself but
um
uh every now and then somebody would
come up with uh a photo from Young Guns
too and it was just it was like oh oh
look at you yeah yeah
because it's a it's definitely only now
and then but it's uh it's always it's
always refreshing I do have a a question
about a piece of Young Guns two
memorabilia that I own but is not
necessarily with me and my person
currently we'll get to that in a minute
but I do want to transition a little bit
into your your current show succession
which is such a monster hit on HBO and
you know Jacqueline I don't know if you
look at this the same way but in the
same way that Young Guns too there's
like a wrestlers to whose gang it is
because Arkansas Dave wants it to be his
gang and Billy wants it to be his gang I
kind of feel the same thing with all of
Logan Roy's children where they're all
sort of vying for the company and maybe
that would have been a gang in the old
west so you because Alan you've been in
so many great ensembles over the years
what is it about this particular
a group of folks that that make
succession so special
I I actually think there's such
despicable characters they're really the
worst people on planet Earth I mean
they're really terrible they really are
um even even my guy Connor who seems
fairly benign he's a sociopath you know
he has no idea how the rest of the world
works that people actually have to work
for a living and worry about paying
their bills and worry about health care
and you know where the kids are going to
go to school and he doesn't have to
worry about any of that stuff has no
idea that what regular people go through
but the people that they've cast in
these roles
to a person uh are extremely likable
even lovable uh Brian Brian Cox who
plays this monster he's the biggest
sweetheart you've ever met in your life
I mean just full of fun you know he's
just he's a wonderful guy all of them
Sarah uh uh you know Jeremy Kieran uh
they're just uh Matthew McFadden who
plays Tom they're just really funny
lovable people and so there's just
something about their innate likability
that takes the edge off the extreme
of who these people truly are you know
and it draws you in a little bit when
the the first when the show premiered a
few years back
a lot of critics were saying I don't
know about the show there's nobody to
root for and I've never understood that
because you know I I my my story is if
we were making a movie about the Nazis
hopefully you wouldn't be rooting for
anybody no you know but um it's
fascinating to see these people who will
basically
they cannibalize each other you know I
mean it's like Logan Roy is like Saturn
and he will eat his children yeah you
know so I I think um I think it's fun to
watch billionaires self-destruct and I
also think that since these people are
being played by actors who are
innately lovable that it just somehow
draws you in
I agree I also like just thinking about
succession because again not to be like
I feel like all I'm talking about is the
music but the underscore of all of this
drama is like first of all the writing
which is so smart but also literally the
score by Nick bratel like they're every
moment of I would say interesting
dialogue you know so many folks at the
end of season two were talking about
that pull out shot where Logan sort of
gives that half smile after Kindle
through so hard to the bus I just feel
like the height of that was hearing Nick
score underneath it is literally the
soundtrack of my entire writing life is
everything uh that Nick Patel writes but
I I really love the show and it starts
with that just that theme song like
somehow it's it's so
bizarre it's it's just it's kind of like
a bad dream it's like it's like the
soundtrack to a bad dream it's not
totally overwhelmingly scary but it is
it's slightly Sinister yeah it is weird
it's a little weird because that's the
show I fire up on Sunday nights right
after after whatever Sunday Night
Football game just aired then I watched
succession and then I I want to prepare
myself for bed but you're right the the
combination of that score with the
opening sequence being like old-timey
home movies that could very easily be
the opening of a horror movie
it kind of is though if you think about
some of the stuff these folks have done
um too man it's interesting too with
Connor I love seeing his sort of like
I'm not gonna get my hands dirty but
he's obviously like so dirty about it
and my favorite thing from him was his
disillusional chick like trying to be an
artist I really felt like every actor on
that set could relate to that person
because we all all know that person like
the talent is few but the finances are
large let's just put it that way
did you have fun with that one oh yeah I
mean she's uh Justine Loop is just so
talented and she's I do most of my stuff
with or at least up to this point I have
done most of my stuff with Justine and
she's just so eat just wherever you go
She'll follow or she comes up with great
ideas and so she's just the back and
forth is really easy
um but yeah that was very funny that
this uh former call girl is is now a
playwright
[Music]
but why not I mean you know why not
people reinvent themselves all the time
and so more power to her and obviously
she had talents that got her there so
more power to her
God gives everybody something right
abilities talents however you want to
frame it skill sets
I was given something and just kind of
bringing this interview full circle here
so it's not currently in my possession
but I am the proud owner in name of a
framed full-length Young Guns to poster
that was given to me years ago from one
of my pals bran Chandler missed movies
but I brought it to the studio where I
was filming a lot at the time collider
and I had it framed right next to my
desk and as a joke one of my other Pals
Nathan took it when I wasn't there
because we're all like I'm on a text
chain with Young Guns 2 fans and that's
all we talk about and so he took the
poster and then my friend Dorena had it
for a while who's been on The Show Ken
Mark Riley a number of people have been
in ownership of this poster and so
that's why I don't have it here to show
off but in classic Young Guns Too
fashion from the words of Alan Ruck
Henry William French himself who should
have the poster because it's almost like
if we're talking about Outlaws here the
owner like I never stole a poster from
someone I didn't like is Nathan's line
so maybe maybe I should never have the
poster in my possession again how do you
see this poster conundrum Alan I think
it's crap I think it's your poster and I
think they ought to give it up I'm just
I'm sorry I think I think it was a
really good joke I I think maybe it'll
go out a little longer but at some point
that the poster needs to come home it
really does you hear that boys and girls
it's my poster and I'm putting it up
here and I don't get damn whatever
anybody else tells me I'm putting that
Young Guns to poster up in my humble
abode uh yeah before you get out of here
though sir we definitely want to go
ahead and if you could please give us a
movie or t TV streaming recommendation
because we like to hear what you're
watching yeah sure I I
uh I got remarried some years back and I
have small children again I have grown
children but I have small children so
I'm really tired
um uh because I'm like an old dad
um and my wife and I me Ray and I don't
get out that much we're kind of in a
babysitter drought right now but not too
long ago we went to see free guy with
Ryan Reynolds yeah it was really really
enjoyable and he's uh he can kind of do
anything Ryan uh my my wife worked with
him I we know him a little bit and he's
uh he's just a really talented fellow uh
a really likable leading man he can do
anything and it's a funny wonderful
movie I thought
and uh and you know and and from Alan's
own words he said maybe there's one more
Western left in and we'll have to wait
on that could it be Young Guns three
that's we'll have to be back when that
movie
there's an adductors right now
I was gonna say Alan have you heard
these Young Guns three
three yeah John Fusco had a meeting and
they uh they tweeted out we're talking
so wow that's exciting I will be about
it listen I will be about it Kiefer made
hideous fun of me on that movie because
um I wore that big old farmer hat you
know and uh they had two one for me and
one for the stunt guy the stunt guy's
name is Berkey Lily he's Jack Lily's son
big you know strapping dude Burkey great
guy he's a stunt coordinator now
um but the the costumer gave the the
proper hat to Berkey and they were off
doing second unit somewhere and my hat
was much floppier and every time we'd
start riding like this my hat would blow
up like this and Kiefer would laugh his
ass off and say you look like you have a
flower pot on your head because instead
of being flat it was just like like that
oh my gosh you're looking like uh
Curious George the The Man in the Yellow
Hat oh yeah I didn't know it looked like
oh yeah you run up into the sunset and
it looks like goofy
disappearance Over the Horizon well it
was it was not goofy it was Buckshot
George for a brief moment there but
Henry William French played by the great
Allen Rock and Alan thank you once again
for gracing us with your presence it was
a blast thanks thanks for having me
thank you have a great day you too bud
thanks so much well Jacqueline I can
dine out on that for the next 30 years
until we do get a proper sequel reboot
of Young Guns what just what a fantastic
talk and and the fact that Alan Ruck was
just so giving about stories from the
set and stuff like that it really made
my week yeah I think we got him to talk
about stuff he said he never talked
about before with Coburn I honestly if
for folks that are watching this on any
of our video formats both Mark and I
were cheesing through this entire video
so I hope you get to enjoy that and yeah
man this was I've enjoyed all of our
certified fresh guests do not get me
wrong but this one's this one was for
the home team as we like to say that's
right and we uh we hope to get together
at some point soon with Jacqueline
myself producing Lucy Brian Perez our
great engineer to look at some of the
the the the broadcasting options we have
but then I need the whole team to come
over to my place and look at where we
put my Young Guns to poster because
according to Henry William French
himself that is my poster it's my
property and it belongs in my apartment
so we'll see if that ever comes to pass
but in the meantime thank you everybody
for listening Jacqueline we don't have
an email today but our listeners can
email us anytime because they are all
certified fresh members of our ketchup
crew the email is RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com you got a movie you
want us to talk about coming up let us
know and we'll do our best to get it on
the docket in the meantime that's
Jacqueline Coley I'm Mark Ellis for the
entire team here at Rotten Tomatoes and
the great Henry William French Alan rock
thanks for listening and we'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]